well that's one the biggest difference
is when you come from college or a
different program to the NBA everyone is
athletic everyone has it all James look
to the left and it's tipped home by
Davis with the Hawks spent time on the G
League and he had weight issues ice past
that brought for the key the one-time
warrior thought he was fouled
now James in a belay Matt nice pass
again and it's Davis this time building
that chemistry early
nice pass for care about the Lakers
screen is off on a three back tapped by
McGee Bob and McGee puts it home and
they've seen that work by JaVale McGee
and if they're here in California they
have 14 new players on their roster
here's James with the hard drive
accounts so right wrist this is what he
does he loves and embraces the contact
mr. hit is but his advantage coming at
you full estate Alfonso my kitty was
only fitting the first three in this
building comes from Steph Curry
JaVale McGee taking advantage of the
lack of height that comes LeBron James
Green on the ketchup shoots the 30 how
valuable is it going to be for the
Brooklyn pets mass broken up recovered
by rabo'ah just come on here's green
this time rather than a hip two three
Davis is right there there's that height
difference you were talking about
it's local here every single vendor is
from the bay area serving derriere
classic also a big concern was parking
scope when a fan buys at the little
things on this Lakers team Rondo getting
inside old and beautiful
what for Davis so appetit Davis able to
put it down
Marquis crisp side just the other day
firstly the first off headline
Sacramento and the Laker onslaught
continues chemistry is already on point
[Applause]
possession tight Daniels seventieth man
from Virginia Commonwealth has checked
in as Rondo sets it up here's Howard put
down by Davis doesn't even take a phone
call for magic to LA kids you know and
goes to the Clipper it's real Oh LeBron
James taking to the rim ends up on top
of the campervan as he threw the foul on
by the way this is his 17th NBA season
okay you know he had like five hundred
and fifty shots in college 311 over
threes and the bronze gonna get a block
there and he's in their stricken area I
think that's gonna save a lot of wear
and tear on LeBron as well because now
he doesn't really have to be the man
until he has to be the man yeah you can
lean on these young guys for first route
picked up the Atlanta Hawks last season
two years ago he was the Big East
Freshman of the year and helped lead Jay
right hand of subtly is that possible is
this possible as we see them way
downtown curry that came up well short
brought James battling for that
rebounded
putting it home almost five weikath at
the 5 and the broth at the 4 which puts
the defender the power cord to the
terrible physician open flame for green
at the February trade deadline that
became public knowledge that the Lakers
were attempting to make the trade for
Davis go to three points seven-point
lead the Lakers Davis gonna draw the
foul counts
move on dream on clue by DeMuth that's a
good call as I say are you all right are
you gonna are you gonna use your
challenge over there no I was okay
that's a good call you should challenge
oh no I was good that's a good call here
is Rondo was approached a minute
remaining in this first half
open the free-for-all goes I agree Reds
I think we're gonna see Rondo shoot more